hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was played in the 70th
women's uh russian championship uh this
year it
was played two days ago it was suggested
to me just today so i checked it out and
it really is
quite the game so it's being played in
the central chess club in moscow and uh
well without further ado let's just
check it out uh both of them are
very strong players and the gallamova is
even a three-time world champion uh she
won the world championship two times um
twice under 16 and once as as a junior
so uh without further ado uh let's check
it out uh
galamova opens with knight to f3 and
like i said this is a game from round
seven
sorry about that uh and uh even though
two more rounds have been played but i'm
only
i've only seen the game now so knight to
f3 uh galamova opens with
the retti opening and here we have
knight to f6
we have c4 g6 and we go into the d4
bishop to g7 the king's indian defense
by black
and here knight to c3 or g3 would be the
most common options for white here
again over goes for somewhat rarer e3
we have castles by black and now bishop
to e2 and here
d6 uh preparing to shift the knight over
to d7 and then strike in the center as
one usually does in a kings indian
defense uh we have castles and now
knight b to d7 knight to c3 both of them
just continuing development
and e5 now striking in the center and
now
b4 it's a very usual in the king's
indian that
black will want to attack on the king
side try and checkmate the white king
whereas white will
try and play on the queen side so here
b4 this is all very standard theory and
now
e4 changing this knight knight back to
d2
and now rook to e8 uh defending the pawn
one more time
and here uh most common moves are queen
to c2 for example in the a4 but here we
have bishop to b2
and it is as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game here
so uh black continues uh shuffling the
pieces uh knight to f8 preparing
h5 and then the knight can come to h7 to
g5
and so on help out with the attack and
white continues just pushing on the
queen side so a4
and h5 and here uh queen to b3 to
support the pushing of the pawns
knight eight sorry that's not the knight
knight eight to h7
and now rook f the c one so uh the one
thing i
love about the kings indian uh is that
uh it's
as if the players are ignoring each
other uh white is playing on the queen
side and black is playing on the king
side so
excellent stuff bishop to f5 continuing
development
and now just a5 and here not allowing a
white to overextend here
uh black plays a6 but we do have
b5 and here uh you might uh
well uh you might treat this move uh
with with
with a few different ideas for example a
captures on b5 is possible but then
after captures it will be very easy for
white to
uh create a pass pawn uh very quickly so
instead after this b5
move we have c6 putting more pressure
here on b5 and here
uh just b captures in c6 uh ganemova
decides to trade we have b
captures on c6 and now uh you have to
decide
what to do uh with the queen here
because the b file has opened up now and
most likely black will play something
like rook to b8 so
queen to a4 is one such option going
after the c6 pawn
uh however galamova goes all the way
back queen to d1
uh expecting black of course to start
pushing those pawns in front of the king
and
um wanting to set up some sort of a
defense here so
knights the g5 and bishop to f1 now the
bishop will nicely help out
with the defense here and now bishop to
g4 attacking the queen and queen back to
e1
so uh somewhat a passive position for
the white queen but
if it works why not we have queen to d7
connecting rooks developing the queen
and now comes bishop to a3 now
here you have to be very careful to not
not to play move like h3 because this
queen bishop battery could just you know
uh come completely destroy your king
side for example bishop captures
captures captures with
check and now it's very hard to to
decide what to do bishop captures queen
captures
and yes you could play something like
queen f1 queen back to f5
uh but it's uh white will have a
terrible time bringing
her pieces into the game and black will
start pushing that h pawn
it's going to be even though white might
be better here it's it's going to be
incredibly difficult to play this
so instead after this queen to d7 move
with bishop to
a3 and now comes rook a to d8 now the
queen can move the d6 pawn will be
defended
and here c5 putting more pressure on
that uh square here
with d5 black of course still wants to
attack on the king side that's black's
plane and of course you do not want to
open up the center you want the center
closed and then you
you can attack uh we have rook uh
seat to b1 putting the rook on an open b
file
going after rook to b6 to try and attack
those pawns
and now queen to f5 black like i said
white is ignoring black black is
ignoring white with rook to b6 going
after that a6 and c6 pawns
and now rook the c8 black defends the c
pawn but gives up the a6 pawn and now
rook captures on a6 and here
it's basically can black get an attack
going and completely ignore being down
material or is this perfectly fine for
white white can just move the rook and
for example
push the a7 or put the 81 to victory so
this is what happened bishop to h6 white
black starts bringing more pieces into
the attack the point is
at some point you are hoping for the h
file to open up you want to play king to
g7 and then somehow
make use of the h file for your rooks
and here uh you could go just rook b6
start pushing that pawn
uh but here we have queen to be one here
uh galamova wants to go queen to b7
probably rook a7 put some pressure
uh on that seventh rank and uh at some
point start pushing
that pawn but here knight to e6 by black
and here uh kashin skye is uh a sort of
stopping queen b8 because if you go
queen to
a queen to b7 and then uh you have this
very unpleasant knight captures on the
e4
and now uh oh you know whole hail will
break loose you cannot capture because
the knight is now undefended
and if you go uh for example rook a7 go
after the pawn rook f8 is coming and
then it's uh
well it's very very hard to make sense
of this position could uh could go in
in any direction so here not over
complicating we have rook to
a2 and now comes now the knight of
course is defended and the queen can
be transferred to b7 but now queen to g5
and again what do you do here we have
rook to b6 getting the rook out of the
way preparing to push the pawn
and bishop to f5 now we have queen to e1
and now comes knight to g4 so uh slowly
but surely
uh those pieces are getting closer and
closer to the white king queen h4 with
the idea of just checkmating the white
king
is black's plan so here uh you could go
something like bishop to a6 attack the
rook place the bishop on b7 and then you
have
uh you know three moves to pawn
promotion however black decides to play
knight to d1
and here we have queen to h4 here you
you
uh queen to h4 with the threat of
checkmate is is a good move
but there is a an even sneakier one
there is
knight captures on d4 and this is not
completely crazy for example he captures
queen to h
for now threatening checkmate but now
after h3 defending now
e3 and again this is just complete
madness who
uh who who can make sense of of this
position everything is hanging here it's
uh very hard to play do you allow e
captures on f2 do go knight f3 attack
black's queen
a lot of interesting possibilities is g3
a move because then the h3 pawn is
defended
so this is one very interesting way for
black to play this but okay uh we have
queen to h4
going for this threat immediately h3
now pushing the knight back and now
knight backed sorry first and that
knight back
knight the g5 and again black is now
offering a full piece so it's uh
definitely very dangerous to capture the
knight but it's not all that clear
how black will break through but one
thing you do not want to do
is allow black to open up the h file and
that's exactly what you will do if you
capture the knight then the king can
come to g7 the rook can come to h8
and black will be able to use the h file
for the attack but uh
white also needs only a few moves to get
to that pawn uh that a pawn up the board
so here a6 is a is a very sensible move
however we do
have uh h captures on g4 uh ganymove
accepted the challenge
and this is what happens h captures on
g4
and now g3 attacking the queen
as the bishop covers the h3 square but
there was another very interesting idea
a6 and it seems like
uh it's very hard for black to make
use of the openh file but there's the
very unpleasant knight f3
check and this is just very ugly for
example if knight captures or g captures
doesn't really matter g
captures now the black king will simply
move and the h
file will be very very
useful for black for example queen h5
and now let's say a7
you're just going to play bishop to g5
move the bishop away from the h file
and the position is completely closed
and white has no moves
that would allow for uh for a third-year
defense for example rook ab2 going after
the b8 square
just king g7 and now if rook to b8 black
is always faster rook h8 and it's game
over
so this is one such thing that that
could happen here
uh so instead after this uh whole whole
madness here we have g3 attacking the
queen and now
just queen back to h5 and here again
it's very hard for white to make a move
you you really have to figure out what
happens if knight f3 if knight h3
so uh white decides to give back some
material she plays f4 and now uh
well the rook now controls the entire
second rank also the queen has
access to the f2 square and maybe white
can defend this however we have
g captures on f3 alpha song also he
captures an f3 is possible in this
position black decides to go
g captures on f3 and now knight to f2
the point is white wants to move the
bishop bring this knight over to
uh to f1 and then all of these squares
will be guarded by
by two knights and the hopefully the
white queen uh the black queen will not
be able to do anything about it
so king g7 uh alina just continues with
her plan the rook is coming to h8 and
bishop to a6 now white also ready to go
bishop here push the pawn to victory
so rook to c7 uh and now comes
knight to f1 so these three squares are
now covered by the knights and it's not
going to be
easy for black to make a breakthrough
here so
rook the h8 as planned and now bishop to
b7
uh and here uh the the the very powerful
bishop to h3 uh so as you can see
for for the rook to be able to do
something on the h file this bishop has
to move
and so far uh the king and knight are
blocking uh
the bishop's path so we'll see what
happens here bishop to h3
and now comes a6 uh galamo just
continues pushing her pawn
point is if you capture here for example
knight captures then it's just knight
captures and you run into checkmate
the king is in check you have to go in
front of the black queen these two
squares are covered by the pawn and by
the knight so king h1 and now
a double check from the queen and the
knight knight f2 check
king g1 and now queen h1 check king
captures and queen g2 will be checkmate
so you have to be very careful
so here instead godamola goes a6 and now
comes
bishop the g2 so what do you do now
uh here we have a7 now finally that pawn
reached the a7 square but now uh bla
white is actually completely lost uh
it's a forced
checkmate in six moves so feel free to
pause the video
and win this position for alina while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations
uh on spotting the move as this is the
position from the
from the thumbnail and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen to h1
with check which is very interesting as
the knight covers that square
but it doesn't matter it's this is
perfectly
uh enough uh to win this to win this
position so the only move for white here
uh is to accept the queen sacrifice
knight captures on h1 but now
this knight no longer guards the h3
square
and as the bishop is defended knight to
h3 is
check we have king to h2 and now comes
the finisher
bishop captures on e3 and with this
bishop captures on e3 move
the h file now opened up for the rook
and there is no
good move for white here whatever you
play you are completely lost
uh because uh well the most obvious
choice is
something like uh queen captures on e3
but the then is just a discovered uh
check knight to f4 check now the rook
becomes uh fully operational king to g1
rook captures on h1 with check king f2
and now
rook captures on f1 is checkmate and the
pawn uh
covers all of the squares so that's
that's it the bishop
defends the rook and there is no
escaping this
and uh yeah there there's uh no no other
defense
after this uh uh bishop captures on e3
uh for example you could try capturing
with the knight but it's uh
it's all the same you just go knight to
f4 check again king to g1 and the idea
is the same
but only now it's rook captures here uh
king to g2 and
now of course not this because the queen
and knight cover that square
but knight the d3 or knight to h3 is
checkmate i'm gonna play the d31 as it's
much nicer
a nice royal fork checkmate so this is
uh
this is a brutal position in the brutal
game so after
bishop to e3 uh white of course is
resigned and
well this beautiful beautiful
masterpiece was
created and even trying something like
g4
uh maybe trying to create some breeding
room for the king
uh falls victim to knight to f2 another
discovery
from the rook this is with check and now
it doesn't matter you can even go to g3
but
then uh the incredible knight captures
on h1 is checkmate
a nice beautiful knight to checkmate the
bishop covers these two squares the rook
completely cuts off
uh the white king from the h file and
the the
there just aren't any moves here so
it's very rare that you will see such uh
such a position in such a
such a fierce uh attack uh in modern
chess
but yeah after bishop captures an e3
white resigned and
like i said this this amazing game was
was created uh so yeah uh that's the
game
round uh seven of the women's russian
championship the 70th edition i do hope
you enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank uh tony mo at
guitar nils neutch uh phil gambetza
steve green and gwen hauser for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day